alors quoi de beau bonjour à toutes et à
tous bienvenue dans votre météo du
week-end alors quoi de beau ce weekend
sachez que déjà lundi c'est férié c'est
lundi de Pâques
c'est lundi de Pâques
il y a des œufs c'est la fête
normalement ce weekend il pleut pas à
part une pluie 2 apparemment puis deux
d’œufs
le température elle remonte elle remonte
elle remonte petit un petit peu mais pas
trop non plus ok donc faut pas s'exciter
non plus on sort pas le maillot de bain
encore mais on va pas tarder quoi parce
que ça remonte mais pas trop non plus
donc c'est cool mais pas non plus hyper
cool quoi hop là
avec la sieste j'ai un petit jeu pour
votre week-end au repas de famille ça
marche super bien la grosse cloche sonne
la grosse cloche sonne la grosse cloche
sonne la grosse cloche sonne je
suis super fort et maintenant on va voir
si vous n'êtes pas c'est super dur et
puis on va voir du coup si vous n'êtes
pas coupable
on va voir si vous n'êtes pas cap ou pas
cap
joyeuses pâques
est-ce que vous fêtez pas monsieur et
non je ne le fait plus
comme ça merci est-ce que vous faites
des pâtes par hasard
est-ce que vous faites des Pâques je
pense que oui si vous êtes chocolatier
est-ce que vous faites des Pâques parce
que vous avez des techniques pour cacher
vos œufs vous oui
que dans le jardin il y avait il y avait
de quoi faire en fait c'était de prendre
beaucoup de très petits œufs là-dedans
là ouais dedans
[Rires]
faut visiter ma boutique c'est là où je
l'ai cache alors là par exemple visible
pour les enfants c'est il faut que ce
soit visible mais pas visible voilà ok
par exemple dans le trou là le petit
trou là là
donc dimanche vous le mettez là
la boutique et vous mangez quand même du
chocolat le dimanche non d'accord et
joyeuses Pâques du coup
mais comment vous faites vous
réceptionner les cloches bah là il y en
a deux qui se présentent comme ça que je
viens de croiser dans la rue
non non mais c'était effectivement des
questions mais c'est des questions
primordiales
[Musique]
on cherche des œufs je sais pas si il y
en a dans le dans l'établissement
peut-être que je me mette à chercher
mais donc là ça aussi c'est du chocolat
ça aussi
tout est-ce qu'on peut faire avec du
chocolat plein de choses des robes
n'importe quoi c'est des costumes c'est
du chocolat là ça pourrait
ça pourrait c'est pas du chocolat
alors quoi de beau